it's not often that your home nation
sells where you live to another country
and by extension
you with it but this is what happened to
the creoles living in french louisiana
when it was sold to the united states in
1803.
suddenly going from being a french
subject to living in america must have
been pretty odd which raises the
question
how exactly did the creoles react to the
louisiana purchase
before we begin it's necessary to
discuss the word creole
nowadays it has a racial connotation to
it but it's important to note that this
wasn't the case until the mid-1880s
and as of the louisiana purchase creole
just meant francophone person born in
the new world and said that's what we
use here
so when jefferson purchased louisiana
from napoleon it was to put it mildly
sparsely populated
the non-native american population there
was about 60 000 people
over half of these people were slaves
and of the rest the major groups were
french spanish german and irish settlers
now whilst louisiana was sold by france
it had only belonged to france for about
two years at this point and totally in
secret
they had gotten it from spain who in
turn had won it from france in the seven
years war 40 years prior
and napoleon had been negotiating the
sale before he'd even sent a governor
there to
you know run the place as such you can
see that the people there weren't
exactly attached to the idea of french
sovereignty
since the only difference was that for
about a year there had been french
troops in the region instead of spanish
ones and then all of a sudden those left
and it was american troops in their
place
and even when it was under spanish
control it was done with a light touch
and so any changes in leadership had
little effect on those living there
especially those in rural areas
so how did the people feel about all of
this well the response was mixed
you see the united states didn't make
this land a state but a territory
this meant those who lived there got the
negatives of government like taxes but
were none of the positives like
democracy or citizenship
instead they got the potential future
maybe promise of one day prospectively
becoming citizens
perhaps for most of new orleans and st
louis's populations
they were furious and many took to the
streets to protest their sail and more
importantly they're being forced to
become americans
now with these changes also came
opportunities particularly with respect
to the mississippi river and trade
the us government wanted the river to
become central to continental travel and
commerce
and so its leaders pledged to make it
more navigable and also rid it of its
piracy problem
and so locals in new orleans knew that
their city would likely become a major
trade hub which it did
however this opportunity brought many
american settlers to the city and they
had no interest whatsoever in mixing
with the creoles already there
as for the rural settlers of louisiana
they weren't so keen
for them their recession to the united
states could only mean one thing
new all-american neighbours which meant
more competition and importantly worse
relations with native americans
whom under spanish and french rule had
largely been left alone and if they were
provoked by these new owners it could
lead to retaliation which wouldn't be
directed at those in washington but
those living on the frontier
irrespective of what they thought the
deal was already done
and the louisiana territory would
forever be incorporated into the united
states
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons
james bissonette mr wolfe kelly
moneymaker sky chappelle rob d
martin captain cydog marvin cassell mo
aaron the white adam stalter jordan
longley boogerly wuggley gustav swan
jerry lamdin rasheed ali gareth turner
maggie patzkowski coppertone winston k
wood spinning three plates corso wolff
marcus asner spencer lightfoot matthew
shipley the mugwopper alex schwinn
lil brepantisi robert wetzel anthony
beckett charles the first and scottish
trekkie